the One X is HTC s attempt to throw
absolutely everything they can at a
single device and from the outside in it
really shows and this is a contender for
one of the best smartphones of the year
in 2012 no doubt so without any further
ado let's take a look at this quad-core
beast so starting at the outside on the
left there is a microUSB port and on the
right is just the volume rocker which
means up top you have both the power
button and unfortunately the headphone
jack I say unfortunately because it
should really be at the bottom but
that's okay
so the thing people talk about when they
talk about the One X is a ridiculously
good build quality it's built like a
boss precision milled unibody
polycarbonate design a very thin
slightly curved body a matte finish on
the back and overall pretty sexy design
up front we have the 4.7 inch Super LCD
display that's kind of the star of the
show and I mean it's just really really
thin I mean look at that check that out
that's very pocketable no matter how big
it looks so you're looking at the back
here which is where you get that 8
megapixel camera with a flash which is
nice and we'll get into that in a second
and the speaker which claims to have
Beats Audio I mean I guess that's
alright it sounds fine to me it's a cell
phone speaker and up front and at the
top they are these precisely milled
holes for the cell phone speaker and one
of these holes holds the notification
light which is pretty nice a subtle
touch and there's also that front facing
camera and all of this is in a package
that's pretty easy to hold you know
doesn't feel that large to me at all I
mean that may be because I'm coming from
the size of the Galaxy Nexus which I'm
very used to but they take up about the
same footprint here so that's nice so
yeah it passes the hardware test so onto
the software now just FYI this is the
quad-core unlocked version of the One X
so it's running a 1.5 gigahertz
quad-core Tegra 3 processor which is
just not fair it's just stupid fast it
flies through ICS and makes it look easy
too I can tell you that during everyday
use this was one of the most
consistently impressively fast phones
I've ever used and that Tegra 3 clearly
has no problems here and to top it all
off some tasty benchmark results yeah
like a boss it's running Android 4.0
point three and has the latest version
of sense
you eye version for now some of us may
not like this and others may you know
brings a lot of functionality there are
a lot of awesome HTC widgets included
like the clock and some the crazy extra
animation some gaudi visual effects and
3d twirly stuff and to be honest some of
you may like that i happen to prefer a
stock android but hey if you like Sense
UI or if you don't mind it that's
totally cool it just helps a lot if you
already know what you're getting
yourself into you because HTC does
change a lot around Android 4.0 as you
can see just kind of makes it its own
little HTC Sense playground if you will
anyway I use it an app called CPU spy to
check on that Tegra 3 and it looks like
it can clock all the way down to 51
megahertz but spends most of its time at
475 megahertz and what it really needs
to push some pixels it hauls up to 1.4
gigahertz and sometimes 1.5 one way to
get it to do that is to play a game no
not Angry Birds this is Riptide GP
kicking it on a jet ski this time and
yes of course the 1x handles it just
fine very nice
so the screen has been awesome for
gaming and just about everything else
should look good on a massive 4.7 inch
1280 by 720 display now the blacks
aren't as ink-black as the Samsung LED
displays but the detail and the
brightness here on 1x are top-notch so
that's awesome and it's great for
watching videos full screen and all the
other apps that should open full screen
however these capacitive buttons down
here at the bottom are nice but there's
no menu button so when an app needs to
have a menu button you end up with this
giant menu button at the bottom which is
kind of sad and but you know it is what
it is
now the last huge part of buying a phone
this nice is for the camera and believe
me when I say this guy delivers I
mentioned this has an 8 megapixel
shooter on the back and you can take a
look at the sample photos I'll include
some stuff in the description for you
but this is a very very high-end camera
for a smart phone it also has this burst
mode at 3.3 frames per second takes
1080p video and overall is a really good
performer so I can definitely recommend
us if you're looking for a high end
camera in the 1x so there you have it
guys it's an overall an amazing package
of very fast device topped off with one
of the most beautiful displays on the
market and surrounded by awesome
high-quality hardware so what more can I
say other than give this review a thumbs
up if you want to see it compared to
Samsung's quad-core flagship Galaxy s3
either way thanks for watching guys I
really appreciate the ratings and thank
you for all the new subscribers welcome
aboard and I will talk to you guys in
the next video thanks for watching
peace
you